Megan starts off this hour in
Minneapolis hi Megan welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi I'm so excited to talk to
you today
you too are you better than I deserved
how can I help
okay so I just wanted to start off by
saying I am finishing baby step number
two this month and I couldn't be more
thrilled but I do have a bit of a
different question for you today so in
order for us to be able to get to where
we are with the hang-up all right that
my husband brother and his family moved
into our house about six months ago and
we're currently sharing all of our
expenses in the home my question is if
it is a minimum of a five-year plan for
us but wouldn't I go to move out I feel
or I believe that it's fair that they be
incentivized for paying half our
principal on our mortgage how would you
go about incentivizing them they're
going to live with you for five years
yeah we all want to knock through all
right baby steps and live like no one
else so we can live like no one else
later Wow
I have to say out loud I couldn't do
that but if you want to it's like if you
want to it's your choice I don't really
have a precedent for what would be fair
to someone living in your house for five
years and sharing your expenses they're
getting a deal are they not I mean like
half a rent what they would pay
somewhere else right right okay and they
knew when they moved in that it was they
knew when they moved in it was your
house right I don't know that they need
to be incentivized with half of your
principle they're just paying you rent I
don't I don't incentivize a renter that
moves into a rental house with giving
them a kickback for the principle
they're paying off because they're not
paying off the principal I am I'm using
their money to do it but the income off
the rental house but this income they
moved in because they had lowered their
expenses overall you allow them again
because it lowers your expenses overall
one of your expenses happens to be your
house so now I don't I don't think
that's necessary I again I it's hard for
me to kick grap my brain around it
because it's just not something I would
do but but but I'm not saying it's bad
to do it I'm just saying I wouldn't do
it but the I'm not even sure I like my
dog living in the house with me but oh
my gosh and that's my dog oh I'm kidding
not much um now that no I would not
incentivize him I wouldn't do that
but if you want to it's okay but you're
asking my opinion and I I think they're
getting their deal by reduced expenses